best boss in America he cut his own
salary and paid all his workers a
minimum of $70,000 a year we all
remember that now as prices company
gravity payments faces an uncertain
future amid this pandemic those
employees are now giving back Jonathan
Vigliotti shows us how they're taking
voluntary pay cuts we had 98 percent of
the employees offered to take a pay cut
that's got to be inspiring to you it's
humbling it's probably the proudest
moment of my life as leader but it's
also the most humbling Dan price says
his employees at gravity payments a
credit card processing company for small
businesses offered not just a cut but
big cuts 30% 50% some even offered to
work for free price wouldn't let them
but he does say their sacrifice meant no
one will be laid off we'd be on the
brink of disaster
if our employees had not stepped forward
to bailout and save the company we would
have probably about three months before
we are completely out of business
Jessica Moore is gravities Director of
Sales
she offered to cut her salary - why did
you choose 30% that's a huge number it's
really about doing everything that I can
to make sure that everyone in the
company is able to keep their jobs that
pay it forward attitude at gravity
started with price back in 2015 when he
made a decision to take his salary down
from 1 million dollars to 70,000 and
told his employees that they would all
get at least that much he says he was
inspired by a Princeton University study
that showed no surprise emotional
well-being Rises as income Rises that's
got to be even more humbling and
inspiring to you to see your employees
kind of following our lead I bawled my
eyes out for about a half-hour it's like
we're all in this together
and just like the coronavirus we all
have to work together to defeat it for
CBS this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti Los Angeles Bravo and
go Dan price you know they always say
leadership stops starts at the top and
you can see he's got a great mind and an
even bigger heart we love that